izes John Roca with the director of this
new film black Christmas which is a
remake of a remake and then it's a
reboot or a reimagining there's all
kinds of going on here thoroughly
enjoyed it last night the director
Sophia to call us here how are you I'm
doing great Harry yeah I mean you've
been doing this all day this press thing
like how are you feeling about have you
got all your emotions about the movie I
yeah I have I'm really really excited I
think it's a really fun scary movie that
has something to say about you know what
it's like to be a young woman in 2019
and hopefully we'll give people a lot to
talk about when they leave the theater
well certainly did me I mean I went home
right home to my girlfriend I was like
listen I just saw this movie I talked
about this I have to admire the
gutsiness of the film you go right into
this idea of male-female relationships
and college date-rape all of this gets
factored in 2019 and you don't pull any
punches I want to ask you know I want to
say and I want to ask you what was that
process like were you supported all the
way through Blum House or people worried
about it how did this go about for you I
think Blum House is an incredible
company that manages to make movies that
are so fun and so scary but also have
something to say about the darker
aspects of humanity and so that was one
of the things that drew me to the
project to begin with was an opportunity
to work with Blum House and make a movie
in that vein yeah and you've been
actress for a while and you're kind of
moving into directing now I know how
excited were you how did this come into
your I guess into your view how did this
project whether baumhaus called me and
asked me if I wanted to make a new
version of Black Christmas well yeah and
it was really exciting I love the
original so much I think it's so fresh
and modern for its time and I'm really
an exciting movie and I felt like 2019
with all of the conversations going on
about what it is to be a woman in a man
and
then the kind of conflict between the
two that's happening right now it seems
like a good time to reexamine the movie
how much did you have to work on
reimagining up this particular film um
like how much what did you work with
this good the descriptions a lot from
when you first got it to when you
finally started shooting yeah there was
no script
oh when Blum has approached me they said
do you want to make this movie there is
no script but you have to shoot it this
summer and has to come out at the end of
this year so it's really fast process
but you know it was it was really
important to me to make a movie that
that and that was inspired by the way
watching the original black Christmas
made me feel that movie made me feel
like I was watching a movie about real
women who were going through something
really scary and we're having fun
together and it was about these female
relationships and and to make a movie
that had those elements but said it
today and dealing with the kind of
issues that young women go through today
yeah putting this cast together how was
that for you was there a live weather is
there a lot of sessions a lot of
conversations or did you kind of just
pick and choose from what these great
actions are that all of the actors in
this movie I think are incredibly and
Imogen Poots is someone I had wanted to
work with for years and years and years
I've been a fan of hers forever and the
rest of the actresses and actors in the
movie just they auditioned and they it
was just right away those were the exact
people for the roles there was no
question that each of the actors in the
movie were meant to play those parts it
was really wonderful to get to work with
all of them Oh at the end we have a
weird look from rileys characters face
now is there Julie or wide open for
possibility of alternate endings or a
sequel they could go somewhere else so
that to my interpretation of the ending
is that just like in the original where
you you realize that the spoiler alert
the killer has actually not been killed
I wanted to create this sense that the
threat was still out there for Riley and
also for women in general that we can't
just like fall asleep and think that our
fight is over that we always have to
fight and be vigilant and so that's what
that look seemed you know is for me yeah
in the end you that's what you seem to
land on this idea of needing to fight
this thing to keep the fight going yeah
go forward with the fight and that it's
never over yeah
in a moment where you feel comfortable
about it I like that's what things
incurred by one in the the interview
with this last question how important
was it for you to get multiple points of
view out there throughout the movie from
different characters so you were having
these discussions so no one felt left
out had a point of view on it in a
certain way you know it's really
important to me that everyone feels like
their point of view is represented in
this movie and that it's not just men
versus women there are different you
know types of men and there are men who
like want to help and want women to
thrive and succeed and to listen and to
be there in a be a support system for
women and then there are women who maybe
are a little bit more ambivalent about
you know feminism and and women's equal
rights and it was important to me too in
order to have an interesting
conversation I think you have to hear
all points of view and then kind of take
from it what you want and have a
conversation I think that's one of the
most powerful things about the movies a
lot of point of views get represented
and there's no yeah there's all kinds of
guts in doing it putting it out there
for people to cover so you can pull any
punches and I think that's incredible if
you want to take anything away from me
then it separates it from the other two
versions of the film that's come before
so there you go all right well thanks
everybody for watching this interview
with Sevilla technology's director all
black Christmas go see this thing it's a
lot of fun